hi everyone uh my name's uh William boo
Bill Bill boo I'm I'm a professor here
in the uh Department of geology and
geophysics at Yale and uh I guess my job
is basically just to introduce uh
Professor condo and and moderate
questions uh so uh I
I I'm only going to give you a very
short version of what's here on the on
the back of this sheet uh that you all
have Professor condo's uh been at at toi
since 2009 uh prior to that he was at a
the University of ngoya uh for 24 years
and uh he works on a wide variety of
topics uh in the atmospheric sciences uh
with an emphasis on uh chemistry and
physical processes uh doing a fair
amount of actually Institute
measurements uh and he's he's received
numerous Awards uh probably many of us
here would uh know uh the American
geophysical Union the agu he's a fellow
of the agu as well as several awards
from NASA so without further Ado
profor
um thank you for your nice introduction
and actually um this is my first time to
visit the year and Professor shun uh
took myself and uh Prof AB to this
campus and uh I was amazed it's very
nice campus and good very good
environment
for for
sinking and uh also
um I would like to thank uh um many
people um in organiz organizing our
visit and also very nice uh uh session
here today uh from y University and and
our University and my a special thanks
to Mike bagani and sh and no he is
organizing um Exchange program in our
University and also
um I'm very honored to to be here to
introduce um some our activities recent
activities in
Japan and I hope that uh this forum will
be a good opportunity in in promoting
interactions between scientists and at
the two two
universities so um I start with my talk
and this is my contents of contents and
I first um uh make some introduction on
relative energy budget of the atmosphere
and probably of the surface uh and also
I touch on climate change which is uh
probably well known in to the people in
this field
and also I I go on Elo effect on climate
and then I I stress need for in
Innovative methodology of el studies and
also advances of studies of effect on
black carbon mainly I talk on black
carbon finary and on
climate um probably you know this F all
quite well but I start with this um um
with this diagram um the
energy of the atmosphere or near surface
is supplied by energy from Sun and uh
about One S of solar energy is reflected
back to space u mainly by scattering in
the atmosphere and also direct
reflection from the surface and the rest
is observed absorbed the rest of energy
is absorbed on the surface and this
energy basically is
is going back to space by infrared
radiation at the surface
temperature but significant fraction of
this infrared radiation is absorbed by
greenhouse gases and also uh roughly
half of
this energy is coming back to the Earth
and this green House Effect has a big
effect if there's no greenhouse gases
the surface temperature will beus 18°
Celsius so ocean is frozen so it's it's
not good environment for
many biological activities but with the
effect of greenhouse gases temperature
the difference in temperature is huge we
have about 15° Cel but this um estimate
can be relatively easily be done by by
simple consideration of uh energy
balance um FN is the energy absorbed by
the Earth and Fs is a solar flux in the
unit of what SCM on average and but only
fraction of solar energy is observed a
is so so arido which is uh effect
Ive deflection of solar energy and also
F out is the INF relation going back to
space so this term sigma0 uh sorry I can
This this term is basically the
um
uh uh is the um
um um energy
uh emitted from the surface but but only
some fraction
of infr energy is okay this one okay uh
is going back to space
because uh greenhouse gases absor a
significant portion portion of uh infr
um energy and we call it f is a fraction
of infate radiation absorbed by
greenhouse gases
and very rather simple rad transfer
calculation can give us some estimate
what F will be and and if we assume that
u f in and F out is balanced which is
there's no change in temperature then we
can simply estimate t0 the surface
temperature by this equation and F is
roughly 0.77 and our V is order of 0.7
and if we put these numbers here but see
s is the physical constant uh Stefan
bman constant and then we get this
temperature so it's amazingly uh
accurate and this equation uses only uh
uh low of backward radiation so it's
very robust equation in a sense and you
notice also that um surface temperature
is controlled only by a and F which Aral
and and and absorption by infrared so
it's simple and Fs is s Fox is probably
constant during many centuries so we can
assume that f is constant so this is the
main point so a and F is the two only
two factors basically controlling the
surface temperature on
average and another important uh
physical quantity is uh R forcing uh
radi forcing can be um expressed this
way um it's a a change in in uh energy
flux at the top of the atmosphere By
changes in in many
by uh chemical or physical changes of
the Earth but in this case if alido
changes for example if
the uh Earth's surface or Cloud changes
then a may change but this change in in
fact can be expressed this way Delta a
multip by FS assuming the temperature is
constant and and
also
go uh the outgoing flux can be also it's
estimated by change in uh Delta F which
is
absorbance that means that change in
concentration of greenhouse
gases and this is so we we called uh
this change as already forcing which
means that U change in flux by change in
in physical
conditions between different uh between
certain period we usually take a change
before uh Industrial Revolution and
after industrial revolution which is now
and the the good um convenient
uh uh the this radi forcing is quite
convenient in the sense that different
chemical and physical processes can be
expressed in the same unit which is in
ener flux wat per square meter which is
very convenient and also another a
second important point of radi forcing
is that the change in surface
temperature can be expressed the first
approximation Lambda multiply by deltaf
Lambda we usually call it uh CL
sensitivity and this includes um uh also
um feedback effect like uh change in um
water paper concentration and also uh Al
by changing ice sheet for example or C
Ice uh it's a bit complicated uh uh
estimate but but important thing is that
Delta F already forcing is a very
critical parameters in predicting change
in in surface
temperature and um f is
mainly controlled by change in
greenhouse gases and all of you know
rapid increase in CO2 in 100 years so I
have not going into that part but I
briefly show that how our is
controlled
uh we can see the important factors uh
from space that you need you see that
the cloud is very bright and this
suggest that solar energy is reflected
efficiently by clouds
also this is pollution over China and
you see hazy uh aerosol particles and
this also deflect uh s sunlight back to
space and another interesting point that
ARA and Cloud interact each other they
look different but they actually
interact this is
interesting although I'm not going to
talk about this uh dation but other
speakers will talk about on this
probably and
then I I briefly talk about the effect
of a on on
climate we have two effect direct and
indirect effect direct effect is like as
I show on on the photo from space uh
sufate or most of the Organics are white
which means that it's reflected and so
sunlight is
efficiently uh reflected back space and
therefore we have less energy absorbed
on the surface so this part first schols
but after that um because of mixing of
air the whole atmosphere will be cooled
by existence
of light scattering
AO but also we have uh black
particles black carbon typically but
also dust absorbs solar energy and and
because of black carbon is black so it
uh absorbs quite efficiently the solar
radiation in visible region and first um
the BC Park is heated and also by heat
conduction and atmosphere locally is
heated but again because of uh mixing
the total atmosphere will be heated but
on the other hand for short time period
U surface coing occurs so this has
another aspect of changing in stability
of the atmosphere and second effect the
indirect effect um um ELO particles
generally um uh as a acts as a uh
nuclear for water paper condensation
because the um when air cools um water
paper is super saturated not so large
super saturation but some saturation
super saturation occurs and in that case
waterpaper condenses on on aoso
particles and and and grows into Cloud
drop rets and basically the number of of
CCN controls the
initial number of cloud particles and if
aoso is larger number of aoso is larger
and Cloud drop number becomes larger and
in that case deflecting deflective
deflectors of cloud in increases and
therefore indirectly uh effect uh in
influence the cing by cloud
but again I'm not going into this second
effect um there old estimate how much um
El will affect the radiation budget uh
this is CO2 um R forcing between 84 1840
to 2000 this is a bit old data about it
1.7 Watt and black carbon this has a lar
uncertainty but it contribute roughly
0.8 probably maybe smaller
0.5 and right SC a is minus 1.3 and and
a indirect effect minus one and you see
the magnitude of this radi forcing is
relative big you see as even as compared
with CO2 uh Heating and uh this
component F and this part is orbal and
uh total direct a coding
is uh of some of these and it's aboutus
0.5 watts and
but uh CO2 gas is quite long lived and
stable and uniform so we have much less
uncertainty as compared to the um
estimate of R forcing by also because
it's short R and and homogeneous
spatially and Ravid changing and Cloud
effect is much more uncertain so we have
still uh large uncertainty is in
estimating ready forcing and U um still
the estimate of uh already forcing in
more reliable ways needed in in making
improved um prediction of climate change
in in
future so here I mainly focus on black
this is uh because one of the reason is
that this is Major effort that we we
made in recent years and this is the uh
I took this finger from recent paper by
Bon edar it's assessment report on on
black carbon effect on climate uh black
carbon is black but in fact it's not
spherical particles it's a a fractal has
structure made of carbon particles
roughly the total size is about 1
micrometer or less than 1 micrometer but
it's a aggregate of smaller
spuse with diameters of about 10 or 20
or 30
Nom and uh BC black C is emitted by
incomplete combustion of fossil fuel and
environments like forest fires so we
have a lot of industrial or human
activities going on and also fires and
biofuels uh also uh causes BC emissions
and as I mentioned BC strongly absorbs
radiation and heat
atmosphere and I mentioned this so also
the the black carbon when transported to
far into the Arctic region and mountain
regions and deposit on the snow and ice
uh it makes
this materials dark and so so it it
tends to melt earlier and it may
contribute to the warming of the
Artic well then I I go into um more
details about the microphysical
properties of of of these and need why
we need to understand um this
microphysics this is the
um rough estimate of absorption
cross-section per unit mass of black
carbon and for Visible range so you
notice that
uh uh efficiency of solar energy by
black carbon is made in small
size very also size dependent mostly the
about 200 nanom par uh most efficient
but but again to to have good estimate
we need detailed information of
of uh size dist distribution and size
has to be known by observation and also
model has to include this information
and another important point of BC and
probably more Jour also that after
emissions during transport of of these
particles
um condens condensation of oxide gases
like saric acid oxide organic species
condenses onto black carbon and make
coating why is it important uh compared
with naked black carbon and compared
with comparing with coding it increases
light absorption up to factor two we
call it lens effect it's so effective
cross-section becomes
larger and another opposing uh effect is
that it tends it tends to act more
effectively as a cloud Nuclear So it it
under super saturation it it grows into
Cloud the saturation of sorry the the
reason why it grows is that because of
oxidation it contains oxygen and oxygen
tend to attract the water paper because
of hydrogen bonding uh hydrogen bond so
it tends to act as a CCN or collect of
water paper under super saturation and
and after that if conditions is good
then it is removed by precipitation so
it's opposing effect is that coating
enhan absorption but on the on the other
hand it shorten the lifetime of BC so
it's the the this effect is rather
complicated if we're going to estimate
the total
effect so um not only for this but uh
recent years we need a new concept for
improved the understanding of as of
direct effect um uh previous effect uh
previous El studies were based on bark
properties typically total mass
concentration but however as I showed R
effect strongly depend on microphysics
especially the number size and mixing
State and uh and also it also has to be
treated as Ensemble of individual
particles not single big particles
represented by total
mass and to achieve this we need the
Innovative Technologies for measurements
also modeling has to be improved
greatly and for this uh we spent a lot
of uh efforts in in having brout
measurement right um we use the Raz indu
incones it's a basic
designs uh So-Cal SP2 which is
commercial available but we made a lot
of modification well the laser beam is
is produced uh by cavity and uh also is
introduced into laser beam and black car
is black and therefore it also young
laser light strongly and and in a very
short time like in microc it heated it
to four about 4,000 de Calin and
therefore it emits a black body
radiation we call it incandescence and
and fortunately the peak intensity of
this radiation is roughly proportional
to to to to the mass of BC and also we
need estimate the coding and this is
more complicated I'm not going into
detail but my codings uh made a nice
algorithm to derive coding by com
combining intensity of of or no um
signal of incence also light
scattering uh time dependent light
scattering
um uh uh uh signal uh simp simply um BC
tends to to heat the coding first and so
signal changes scaling signal changes
but also it emit uh rad black body
radiation with this combination we can
estimate the the total mass Cod coding
BC and also light scattering part is
much easier because it only gives light
scattering so we have all basically all
all information what we need to describe
unem El by this technique but we have
problem with size but still basically
and important point of this uh um
technology that we have no no
interference even if BC is CED we can
estimate total uh uh mass of BC which is
very different from previous
Technologies uh and for modeling uh my
colleagues uh made a lot of effort in
describing both size and and mixing
State according sickness of of BC and we
made uh two dimensional
representation of of this uh
uh State and we with x axis a diameter
and y axis Mass fraction BC and with
this representation changes in number of
Elso and BC and diameters and mixing
State can be
expressed um using based on on chemical
and or representing accur 3D physical
and chemical processes and especially
condensation and curation can be
expressed by this framework of of the
model and uh by making uh in mation we
developed we made the first mission in
in East Asia and uh this is Japan and
this is China is behind this uh figure
but it's a big source of of a and we
Flew Over East China Sea and and and we
went Korean back and Yow seas and for
this flight made in April 2009 we have
21 flights and
uh we have a significant amount of data
using relative small
airplane and this is the um average
mass con Mass concentration of BC blue
one is observed oh sorry I forgot to
mention that the mod flamework which we
made is is regional scale model it is
not Global model it mainly uh covers
only Asian regions including India and
China so this is a regional scale
modeling uh we call it w CAC
model modified version and this uh we
made the comparison with model
calculation along the flight track of
the aircraft so we have uh at least
Factor two agreement between two model
and
observation and and so reason a good
agreement then we look at the global
model uh this is our Air Force um mean
profile and these are the global models
which were used for ipcc a five and uh
also this is a average no not uh the
average for this period but you see
there are a lot of all the magnitude
differences between soal aom
models and uh
so at this at this stage
uh
there lot of difference between models
and another point
that we can understand the models are
different but but we need to understand
why models are so different so we need
um uh another parameters which with
which we can diagnose the performance of
models and wet deposition is an
important parameters for for controlling
the BC concentration in the
atmosphere and uh we estimated the
fraction of black carbon remaining after
emissions from China or Asian continent
and this um we call it transport
efficiency again which is a fraction
which escaped from wet deposition
precipitation and this can be derived by
BC and Co cooperation because Co is
emitted in the same region as BC but not
removed by precipitation and you see in
the banner there below 2 kilm uh the
efficiency transportation is about cross
to one but it decreases Naturally by
pration and it reles about 0.4 in the
mid
troposphere and again I compare this
with wor model ISM are good and also
just came from Harvard University and
it's slightly underestimated but it's
reasonable but when we compare with cs 5
pnnl which is basically an GCM in the in
the fre throp it shows quite large under
estimate so this parameter is is very
convenient and useful in
in understanding
why MS shows different features of VC
profiles and now we are discussing with
uh C five people and and they they know
that they have strong under or
overestimate of pration so they are now
running new version of the model so
probably next week we will have new
result from this and after that we hope
to summarize our
papers
uh um and then we go also uh into the
understanding of how models Regional
scale model represent mixing State share
and
core ratio and this again our
observations this whole period and it
includes the whole period and whole
altitud range and calculation reasonably
uh represent uh
observations uh
so the understanding of coding is
important in in estimating the uh R
forcing
finary and this is microphysical part
but we also went into the um uh
measurement of radiation
itself there are several stations So-Cal
airnet which is or by NASA and it is
deployed of the world and it think some
station in China and in Japan we have
different uh instrument I used uh which
is I for the name uh not AET but Sky
Skynet but similar in
principle and uh and we made use of
So-Cal single scatter arido which is the
um the ratio of total Extinction which
is caused by scattering and absorption
and also the r
scattering and if we subtract from this
single scatter arbid from one it also
gives a good measure for absorption the
advantage of using this parameter single
scale arido is that it is not directly
related to the total mass concentration
so it gives represent the optical
properties of of BC or aoso so it's good
measure and so our original scale model
can also predict single scale
arido and this is a map of single SC
quum average single SC
arido you see
the
uh
yes and in in in China uh sing SC Aro is
large this means that more absorptive in
nature and in outflow from China it's
more this
oh sorry it's revers is it it's
strange sing SC are lower
here is it I'm a bit confused anyway
let's dising this but go go this look at
this figure and AET over China I think I
thought this is correct um sing SC is a
bit lower and and also in in the out
outflow region is a bit High
and this is observation and this is
modeling and uh modeling observation
gives some reasonably uh agreement not
perfect but reasonable I didn't show it
here but if we don't include proper or
predicted uh mixing state or coding this
correlation doesn't hold anymore so the
the coding is really important in in
understanding absorption here in this
region but this is just studing studies
we have not even completed this paper
it's in preparation by my colleagues but
this is good point and so we should
really look at the absorption on the by
ground based measurement like airnet but
the problem is that I didn't show
problem but I'll go back to this
issue um next is that probably uh this
is starting point but emission is
important we have not we but some people
working emission inventory they they
report how much
emission is occurring for for each grade
and about 90% of BC is emitted from
China Japan and Korea is negligable
small but the the emission in estimate
of emission inventory has about 200%
errors
uncertainties and to constrain the
missions we have several stations but at
this for this studies we have okina H
and uh another station fima and and
mountain region Hao 1.8 kilm and we are
not we not have wrong time record uh for
for BC Mass con
concentration because of wrong time
measurement we developed soal Cosmos
instrument which is fut based
instrument very robust and and reliable
with accuracy of
10% and uh we have about three or more
years record and for this we made mon
average with regional scale model and
observation agreement is very good and
with for more detailed
comparison um we estimate that
emission uh of BC by current inventory
is accurate to within 40% Central values
is accurate to within 40% it's a big
difference between 20
40% uh we so groundbased measurement
when made in Downstream of the major
sources it gives a good information of
emissions like China maybe in India with
this similarity similar studies can be
done well uh we don't didn't estimate
the uh Global BC r forcing but bone at
made it using many Global models and
surprisingly BC R forcing is 0.7 watt
which is big and including direct effect
of BC it goes to 1.1 Watts it's again
huge but of course there is offsetting
effect like
uh oric aerosol uh and and
sufate emitted
simultaneously and but going into that
um we have to be careful that this
estimate was made by
constraining uh Model results by
observations of radiation
aeronet and model underestimated factor
three compared with observation so modal
results are m by fact of
three and why there is fact of three
difference between model and
observations there are some
possibilities emission might be wrong
but also absorbance of BC could be
underestimated or M might have
overestimated the with the position so
there are still a lot of uh things we
need to investigate in near
future and also another problem is that
is ground based radiation measurement is
correct this is not our responsibility
but this is another problem but we have
to uh solve these issues uh in near
future so I made summary of my my
presentation we have established new
methodologies or or continuing to
establish and also microix are critical
to
improve critical to improve
understanding of Alo impact on climate
we have evaluated individual key process
by observation and modeling it is a
stepbystep approach we need this
approach and uh we developed instrument
to measure key parameters and made field
observations and we developed new models
to interpret the new data and made
detailed comparison with observation in
East Asia and we are making improved
estimate of Elo effect on radiation and
climate so comparison with radiation is
first step and future um we need more
detailed studies of crow interaction but
we
are weak in this mod efforts and we are
also making observation of Aros Cloud
but because of uh time and I didn't
mention about observation but there's
strong effect of aoso on cloud in East
Asia and these AOL are mainly from
transported from China and E Asia is
strongly influenced by by by this
effect uh finally I I thank my
colleagues uh uh which made a big
contribution to these studies especially
Dr K and Tak and M and Mii and K and Ma
is mainly doing moding works and these
two guys are mainly doing uh
observations and I thank my uh Japanese
Ministry of Education and Ministry of
environment for continuous support of
these programs thank you very
much thank you Professor uh so we'll
take a few
questions